[Musique]
[Rires]
le mythe Charles Manson c'est d'abord et
avant tout des meurtres particulièrement
violents
mais ces actes abominable n'étaient pas
du tout son but premier
la véritable histoire de Manson
c'est la musique
Charlie n'aurait pas été Charlie sans la
musique c'était un poète il croyait
vraiment sa musique
[Musique]
la musique devait servir à diffuser sa
philosophie
[Musique]
en 1968 Charles Manson auteur
compositeur et Guru est un musicien très
en vue à Los Angeles
à peine un an plus tard il est considéré
comme l'homme le plus dangereux au monde
beaucoup de gens ignorent à quel point
Charles avait ses entrées dans le milieu
musical
a produit avec succès des artistes tels
que les Birds ou Brian Wilson et les
Beach Boys Charles Manson se voyait bien
être le prochain sur la liste
tout ça n'aurait jamais pu se produire à
un autre moment le contexte était
parfait quand un homme comme Manson
entré en scène il n'y avait plus aucune
limite plus aucune règle ce film raconte
le rêve de musique qui a animé Manson et
comment il s'était fondé l'histoire de
Charles Manson est l'histoire du rejet
et de l'échec
c'est l'anéantissement de ses rêves qui
a fait naître la folie en lui
[Musique]
Los Angeles le 9 août 1969 au crépuscule
de l'une des décennies les plus
mouvementées de l'histoire des
États-Unis les habitants de la métropole
se réveillent en apprenant que plusieurs
meurtres très violents ont été commis au
cœur de les wood
[Musique]
une croix
les assassinats ne sont qu'une
regrettable formalité à Los Angeles en
étant Californie aux Etats-Unis et les
meurtres par armes à feu ou alarme
blanche sont courants mais ça c'est une
toute autre catégorie une autre cité de
première classe il s'agit quand même du
massacre d'une femme enceinte de 8 mois
et demi et toutes les victimes ont été
assassinées dans un déferlement de
violences absolues c'est bien autre
chose et c'est totalement révoltant
parmi les victimes se trouve une star
d'Hollywood épouse d'un célèbre
réalisateur l'affaire fait naturellement
les gros titres de la presse du monde
entier le lendemain deux autres corps
sont découverts à 30 km de là également
victime d'une intrusion violente dans
leur domicile cette deuxième agression
amplifie l'onde de choc qui secoue la
population locale
on a évoqué la sauvagerie des actes
comiques
certains détails sont sortis dans la
presse et en l'espace de quelques jours
il est devenu impossible d'acheter une
arme à Los Angeles les armureries
étaient en rupture de stock
un chien de garde se vendait 100 dollars
avant les meurtres désormais il fallait
débourser jusqu'à 2000 dollars pour en
acheter un
la police va mettre plusieurs mois à
arrêter les coupables à l'annonce de
leur arrestation le monde est sous le
choc Charles Manson à la tête d'une
communauté hippie ainsi qu'un certain
nombre de ses disciples naïfs
principalement des femmes sont inculpées
pour des meurtres qui comptent parmi les
plus violents de l'histoire américaine
à peine deux ans auparavant la
Californie a été l'épicentre du Summer
of Love où la contre-culture battait son
plein et célébrer la paix et la bonne
entente
mais les conservateurs américains
traditionalistes ont toujours considéré
cette jeune génération avec le plus
grand scepticisme
et plus le mouvement se radicalise plus
il est considère comme une menace
potentielle
avec Manson et sa bande de hippie
meurtrier la menace et désormais bien
concrète
[Musique]
à la ferme Benson ne se sentait en aucun
cas proche de Sharon Tate ou des autres
familles d'Hollywood
ce qui le préoccupait c'était la nature
complètement incontrôlable de cette
jeunesse qui s'était déjà manifestée
lors de contestation étudiante des
émeutes à Chicago ou tout autre forme de
protestation
pour la soi-disant majorité silencieuse
ces gamins n’étaient que des sales
gosses gâtés qui ne cherchaient qu'à
provoquer se droguer et a couché avec
tout le monde
en généralisant et en forçant le trait
on obtient les meurtriers de la famille
même somme
mais l'enquête est un véritable
casse-tête et le mobile des meurtres
reste obscur la presse ne tarde pas à
publier des articles à propos d'orgie ou
de rids sataniques tandis que le
procureur général et la police va
stopper les témoignages de personnes
impliquées une histoire complexe se fait
jour
menson n'est pas uniquement un gourou
solitaire tout comme il n'est pas le
criminel de sang-froid que les supposés
sont profil il est également un auteur
compositeur qui a des relations avec les
stars de la scène musicale de Los
Angeles
début décembre 1969 on voit les premiers
articles dans les journaux de Los
Angeles évoquaient une vengeance de
Manson à l'encontre de Terry Melcher
voir une tentative d'assassinat comme
mobil-home meurtre
Doris Day pour les jeunes américains il
est un producteur de musique connu qui a
travaillé avec les Birds et Paul Rivier
run the riders pour l'Amérique profonde
il est l'enfant de la petite fiancée du
pays
l'enquête se poursuit et petit à petit
plusieurs noms sortent dans la presse
les uns après les autres
évidemment
Jacobson un compositeur ainsi que
d'autres non Dennis Wilson Neil Young
John Philips ou Buffy Sainte-Marie très
vite il est devenu évident que la
musique était une composante essentielle
de cette affaire
[Musique]
le voyage musical de Manson débute ici à
San Francisco en 1967
une ville au cœur d'une révolution
culturelle dès la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale la cité attire ce qui
cherche à s’échapper du carcan
conservateur de la mairie profonde et a
explorer des modes de vie alternatif la
ville californienne est dans un premier
temps le territoire des écrivains de la
[__] generation mais c'est à partir du
milieu des années 60 qu'elle se
transforme en un véritable centre de
créativité avec une jeunesse nourrie de
musique de drogue et d'idées nouvelles
le point névralgique de cette
effervescence culturel et artistique et
le quartier de eight aspery
le quartier s'est développé en 1967 un
peu par hasard
les beatniks étaient établis dans le
quartier de North Beach mais les
logements étant meilleur marché dans
itashbury les étudiants de l'Université
d'État de San Francisco préfère y
emménager
puis arrive les artistes qui créent une
communauté créative et pleine de
vitalité
les musiciens ayoccupent une place
importante
Jefferson Airplane est le premier groupe
du quartier à avoir du succès
tant de personnes créatives au même
endroit se stimule mutuellement il
partage la même vision la lutte pour la
liberté individuelle artistique et
sexuelle c'était dans l'air du temps il
fallait accéder à davantage de liberté
dans tous les domaines
en ce milieu des années 1960 la lutte
pour plus de liberté n'est pas l'apanage
de San Francisco mais elle est le moteur
d'une vision nouvelle
depuis l'émergence des Beatles au début
de la décennie une culture jeune
dynamique s'est déjà épanouie dans
d'autres villes d'Europe et d'Amérique
mais aucun autre endroit n'a eu accès à
la drogue de prédilection de eighthory
le LSD
ce puissant hallucinogène est au cœur
même de l'aventure San Francisco et
façonne la musique l'art et les idées
qui émergent de la ville
si d'autres drogues influent sur
l'humeur c'est la perception de la
réalité qui se trouve considérablement
modifié chez le consommateur de LSD un
seul trip peut parfois suffire à
certains pour ressentir un éveil
spirituel
on ne saurait trop insisté sur le
pouvoir du LSD
certains ont accédé à des états jamais
atteints
et il a transformé leur vie du jour au
lendemain
tout le monde était à la recherche d'une
illumination et le LSD était un
raccourci pour y parvenir il vous
ouvrait l'esprit et vous permettez ou
vous donner l'impression d'entrevoir un
autre mode de vie
mais cela nous rendait aussi tous très
vulnérables face à ceux qui voulaient
profiter de nous
tandis que la contre-culture de San
Francisco commence à avoir une renommée
nationale et internationale au début de
l'année 1967 le psychologue timmo fairy
va se faire remarquer par sa promotion
du LSD en louant publics thérapeutiques
et spirituels
[Musique]
conscience
on atteignait parfois une dimension
spirituelle très élevée quand les gens
parlaient du LSD et de ses utilisations
a donné une sorte de légitimité à ses
idées sur cette drogue et sur le Nouveau
Monde et l'utopie qu'elle révélait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est devenu son slogan défensez-vous
avec de la marijuana ou du LSD
soyez à l'écoute connectez-vous aux
images aux idées aux visions que ces
drogues produisent
et puis laissez tomber la société
on avait l'impression que l'utopie était
à portée de main
le principe était que ce paradis pouvait
être atteint et que le LSD était la voix
qui menait
mais laissez tomber était un message
controversé plus tard il est revenu sur
sa position il ne parlait pas
d'abandonner l'école par exemple il
voulait dire il faut réfléchir à mettre
son énergie au bon endroit
mais le pavé avait été jeté dans la mare
et personne ne pouvait plus rien
contrôler
surtout pas Timothée
et elle était 1967 lors du fameux Summer
of Love de jeunes désenchantés venus des
quatre coins de l'Amérique décident de
tous les laisser tomber et arrive en
masse à San Francisco à la recherche du
l'utopie promise par Timo Fevery
était un quartier où la population était
extrêmement dense
cette communauté aurait peut-être pu
subvenir aux besoins d'un millier de
personnes mais de 1967 à 1969 on estime
qu'environ 300 jeunes débarquaient à
chaque jour
mais avec la conviction qu'on
s'occuperait d'eux une fois sur place
cette situation a donné le champ libre
au prédateur
on a vu alors arriver de tout le pays
des arnaqueurs des trafiquants de drogue
des proxénètes et surtout
attiré par ce merveilleux terrain de
chasse Charles Manson
[Musique]
à son arrivée dans le quartier de
heithbury au printemps 1967 Charles
Manson à 32 ans et il a tout autant
envie de prendre part à l'utopie du
moment que les jeunes qui l'entourent
tout juste sorti de prison après 7 ans
de détention menson cherche tout comme
bon nombre de personnes qui affluent à
San Francisco a échappé à un passé
trouble et apprendre à nouveau départ
dans ce meilleur des mondes
né à sincenatti dans le Loyau le jeune
Charlie n'a jamais connu son père sa
mère est une adolescente célibataire
nommée Kathleen Maddox en rébellion avec
sa famille très croyante
à l'âge de 4 ans seulement Charlie la
voix se fait embarquer par la police
pour volamar mais elle sera condamnée à
5 ans de prison
[Musique]
était un gamin que tout le monde se
refilait il a été confié à des amis à la
famille à tous ceux qui voulaient bien
l'accueillir
ensuite été envoyé chez ses
grands-parents puis chez sa tante et son
oncle en gros il circulait de foyer en
foyer et il a très vite compris qu'on ne
voulait pas de lui il vivait avec sa
tante son oncle et son cousin sa
grand-mère venait lui rendre visite on
ne peut pas dire que les premières
années de la vie de Charlie étaient
parfaites en particulier avec une mère
en prison mais il a toujours eu des gens
aimants qui s'occupaient de lui le
problème bien sûr c'est que Charlie
était dès le début un enfant très
désagréable et très violent
agressif et renfrogné le jeune Charles
Manson trouve toutefois au domicile de
sa tante et de son oncle en Virginie
occidentale de quoi canaliser son
trop-plein d'énergie
il y avait un piano dans la maison de
son oncle et de sa tante
n'oubliez pas que Manson était tout
petit
à cinq ans on lui en donnait trois et
ses mains étaient minuscules
de musique la musique religieuse et la
country
il était très doué
il détestait aller à l'église sauf pour
chanter et quand il le faisait ilimait
tellement de coeur que sa grand-mère
avait l'impression que l'Esprit du
Seigneur était descendu sur cet enfant
son talent naturel pour la musique ne
suffit toutefois pas à freiner sa
tendance à commettre des délits
durant son adolescence Manson se fait
arrêter d'innombrables fois pour vol
avec ou sans effraction
il est impressionnaire régulier de
diverses maisons de redressement où il
peut parfaire sa formation de délinquant
vers 20 ans il décide de devenir
proxénète
Manson était un délinquant sans
envergure toujours mal préparé et donc
constamment arrêté comme son quasi
l'indique
Charles Manson a tout du délinquant raté
il commence par le vol à l'italage il se
fait toujours pincer il vole des
voitures on le retrouve à chaque fois
enfin après avoir appris le métier
auprès d'autres proxénètes lors de son
premier séjour en prison il décide de
s'occuper d'un groupe de filles mais il
ne les garde pas très longtemps
la constante dans ses débuts de
délinquants c'est sa capacité
extraordinaire à repérer les personnes
faciles à manipuler
Manson expliquera plus tard que sa
philosophie pour attirer d'abord ses
prostituées et plus tard ces adeptes et
de toujours trouver celle qui était un
peu tordue ou fêlées mais jamais
complètement détraquée
Manson tente brièvement de s'assagir au
milieu des années 50 en retournant en
Virginie occidentale pour épouser une
serveuse du coin
mais les instincts criminels sont
désormais enracinés en lui à la fin de
la décennie il est à nouveau arrêté au
Nouveau-Mexique pour avoir voulu
s’établir comme proxénète cette fois il
est incarcéré au pénitencier de l'île
macneal pour une peine de 10 ans toute
tentative d'évasion y est impossible
menson apprend alors à jouer de la
guitare et sa passion pour la musique
lui revient
au début ce n'est qu'un passe-temps et
puis en 1964 il entend une chanson à la
radio qui va complètement changer sa
perspective
[Musique]
le pays la musique des Beatles était
extraordinaire dynamique et vivante
elle a tout balayé sur son passage même
ceux qui ne l'aimaient pas été touchés
par le groupe
on ne mesurera jamais assez l'impact
quand il est Beatles sur les musiciens
devenir y compris Charles Manson
tous ceux de cette génération parle des
Beatles et de l'effet qu'ils ont
provoqué dans les mêmes termes
c'était énorme immédiat et tout sauf
éphémère
quand il entend cette musique c'est un
moment qui change tout pour lui les
Beatles n'ont pas fait élargir l'horizon
musicale de Charles Manson il lui donne
une nouvelle ambition
tout ce qu'il voulait auparavant c'était
d'être un proxénète qui gagne bien sa
vie grâce à ses femmes sans avoir à
travailler dur lui-même mais maintenant
il a une guitare
il sait enjoué il a l'inspiration
il commence à écrire des chansons en
prison
Terminal Island Los Angeles c'est ici
que Manson est transféré en 1966 pour
achever sa peine de prison réduite à 10
ans pour bonne conduite
dans cette prison basse sécurité menson
rencontre Phil Kaufman un acteur qui
purge une courte peine pour possession
de drogue
il y avait la promenade dans la cour
tous les jours entre deux travaux et
après le dîner le petit déjeuner on y
faisait les 100 pas et je vois un type
jouer de la guitare en chantant the
shadow of your smile je me suis dit
celui-là il est cool
[Musique]
je me suis approché de lui pour faire
connaissance il a continué à jouer
pendant notre conversation et un gardien
est venu lui ordonner d'arrêter Manson
tu peux pas jouer ici
on joue de la musique dans la zone
réservée à la musique
ça ne l'a pas arrêté pour autant alors
le maton a gueulé d'une sortira jamais
d'ici menson Charlie a répondu sortir
d'où mon pote
et il a continué de chanter
Charlie était cool
il jouait de la guitare et chantait des
standards que j'aimais bien
mais plein d'autres encore
c'était un bon chanteur on aurait dit
Francky Lane une grande vedette des
années 40 et Charlie et moi on était de
cette époque on était plus âgé que les
autres
nos références c'était Frank Sinatra
pericomo ce genre de crooner
en mars 1967 Manson est sur le point
d'être libéré connaissant ses ambitions
musicales Phil Kaufman donne les
coordonnées d'une relation précieuse
qu'il a dans le show-business
quand Carly allait sortir je lui ai
suggéré de rencontrer un ami à moi qui
travaillait dans le milieu de la musique
Gary strumberg je trouvais qu'il était
bon je précise que c'est d'une Charlie
en prison dont je parle donc je présente
cet individu a des gens respectables de
l'industrie de la musique
et ça ne s'est pas du tout passer comme
prévu
quand il est sorti il s'est dit
c'est parti
en prison depuis la fin des années 50 à
sa libération Manson se retrouve dans un
paysage qui lui est totalement étranger
[Musique]
l'Amérique qu'il connaît a été
métamorphosée par la Révolution
culturelle provoquée par l'arrivée des
Beatles avec l'assassinat de Kennedy le
début de la guerre du Vietnam et la
conscription qui voient des milliers de
jeunes hommes embarqués dans sa conflit
auquel il ne croit pas le fossé qui
s'était creusé entre le générations dans
les années 1950 et désormais un abîme
la contre-culture qui se répand à
travers le pays considère les aînés et
les autorités avec une profonde méfiance
et cherche à refaçonner le fameux
American way of life
[Musique]
les gens se sont rendus compte que notre
nation était en faillite sur le plan
spirituel on s'était fourvoyés
et les principes moraux de notre
Constitution et des pères fondateurs
semblaient oubliés
à cause de la guerre du Vietnam des
avancées sur les droits à la sexualité
d'une plus grande sensibilisation à la
discrimination raciale et du mouvement
des droits civiques le pays était divisé
mais pour moi ce n'était pas forcément
négatif nous découvrions de nouvelles
choses
on vivait tous une phase d'exploration
en toute innocence et Charles Manson âgé
de 32 ans a bien l'intention de profiter
de cette innocence il se rend d'abord à
Berkeley puis à San Francisco la ville
lui permet de retrouver sa jeunesse
perdue en prison et il adopte cette
nouvelle culture et son pouvoir
libérateur
le premier geste de Manson et de se
mettre à l'écart pour discerner les
meneurs de cette scène pendant plusieurs
semaines il écoute les groupes locaux
observent les différents prédicateurs et
militants dans le parc du Golden Gate et
prend du LSD pour la première fois puis
il descend dans la rue la guitare à la
main à la recherche de ses propres
disciples
San Francisco grouillait de gourou de
philosophes de prédicateurs de secte de
religion tout ce que l'on peut imaginer
Manson avait sa propre philosophie
on l'appelait le jardinier parce qu'il
se met des graines dans l'esprit des
gens
il avait une formule bien à lui
il était très rusé et charismatique un
showman hors pair et un excellent
prédicateur son numéro sur
l'Intelligence cosmique était très bon
même si je décrochais au bout de deux ou
trois phrases tellement c'était fume
la philosophie de Manson qui proclame
que la morale est un mensonge que rien
n'est corrompu mis à part les
possessions légaux et la famille est un
amalgame de concept tiré de la Bible de
la Scientologie et de gourou de l'acide
qui l'entoure mais elle lui permet
d'attirer un petit groupe de jeunes
femmes
Marie Bonnard Linette from Patricia
kreenwinkle et susannakkins sont toutes
séduites par le charisme de Manson par
sa musique et par l'intimité qu'il leur
promet ce petit harem de disciple allait
devenir la garde rapprochée de Manson
par la suite il a toujours en poche le
numéro de téléphone de Guerry strumberg
que lui a donné Phil Kaufman il fait
l'acquisition d'un autobus scolaire en
novembre 1967 et met le cap au sud vers
la cité des anges son rêve de faire de
la musique est plus ardent que jamais
à ce moment là en Californie tout le
monde devait aller à Los Angeles et se
salir les mains comme le disait friends
à part même les grands groupes de San
Francisco qui se considéraient d'un
niveau supérieur
c'est là que se trouvait les labels et
les personnes qui pouvaient vous
proposer un contrat
Manson est parti à Los Angeles dans le
seul but de devenir une rockstar
[Musique]
en 1967 Los Angeles est une ville
tentaculaire qui puisse son énergie dans
une immense industrie du divertissement
elle est bien la Babylone du cinéma
depuis des années mais son essor en tant
que capitale de la musique est un
phénomène relativement récent
au début de la décennie le secteur de la
musique était principalement concentré à
New York pourtant en 1961 un nouveau
groupe va contribuer à établir Los
Angeles comme ville musicale
portée par l'engouement pour le surf qui
produit sa propre culture de la jeunesse
et un son rock instrumental les Beach
Boys sortent une série de tubes qui va
attirer l'attention nationale
menée par le talentueux compositeur et
chanteur Brian Wilson qui était paulé
par ses frères et cousins le groupe au
son unique et propulsé au sommet du
monde de la musique et vos
instantanément à la Californie une
renommée culturelle
Beach powers
le phénomène de la surf music de la côte
ouest les vagues et le bronzage les
filles en bikini et les gogos danseuses
tout ça fascinait les jeunes du Midwest
allant vivre en Californie un été sans
fin
même les habitants des villes froides de
la côte est la considérée comme un moyen
d'évasion
les gens ont commencé à se rendre en
Californie au début des années 1960 les
Beach Boys ont créé un mythe national
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
leur thématique soleil et surf à la
Californienne plaisait à tous
que ce soit en Amérique ou dans le reste
du monde
c'était comme un prospectus pour un
style de vie qui tentait beaucoup de
gens
c'était de la musique légère
[Musique]
surf music existait déjà mais elle était
surtout instrumentale ou alors les
chanteurs étaient médiocres
et d'un coup Brian Wilson a associé
l'énergie du rock de Chuck Berry à de
splendidharmonie des harmonies quasiment
jazz
c'était totalement inédit
et les Beach Boys n'apportent pas
uniquement les charmes de la Californie
aux adolescents américains en 1964 les
maisons de disques commencent à
s'installer à Los Angeles et suite à
l'impact provoqué par les Beatles et la
British invision les émissions de
télévision musicale deviennent très
populaires et sont tournés dans les
studios de les Vaudes
l'industrie est en plein boom les
producteurs et les découvreurs de
talents partent à la recherche de
groupes locaux pour les propulsés sous
les feux de la rampe c'est là qu'arrive
les birds
ont révolutionné la scène musicale de la
côte ouest du jour au lendemain
l'installation des labels à Los Angeles
en 1964 avait été une première étape
mais les beures ont fixé les bases de la
musique à venir ils ont pris le rythme
et les harmonies des Beatles pour les
mélanger au texte profond de Bob Dylan
[Musique]
un changement s'est opéré à Los Angeles
de toute évidence les Beach Boys étaient
extrêmement importants au début des
années 60 et aller continuer de l'être
mais ce qu'il représentait au moment de
l'arrivée des Birds à savoir la légèreté
le soleil le surf tout ça a pris un coup
de vieux
cette vision d'un monde nouveau
qu'apporte la contre-culture on la
retrouve dans la musique des birds
[Musique]
les Birds ont suffusionner une
sensibilité pop avec une thématique
beaucoup plus profonde chose que
personne d'autre n'avait accompli avant
fin 1964 Dylan naviguait dans ses
eaux-là mais il était toujours considéré
comme un artiste folk il n'avait pas
vraiment atteint les échelons supérieurs
de la pop il n'apparaissait pas dans la
presse musicale pour ado alors qu'on y
trouvait les Birds
les Birds étaient clairement plus années
60 plus moderne
ils étaient des préippis en quelque
sorte David Crosby avec sa cape et
mcgreen avec ses lunettes de soleil
bizarres ils avaient l'air
avant-gardiste leur son était cool
ils étaient parfaitement en phase avec
l'époque
le succès des Birds fait des émules
parmi les groupes de la ville que ce
soit les Doors love ou friends Appa and
the mother Vincent on trouve de la
marijuana bien plus facilement en
Californie que sur la côte Est ou qu'en
Grande-Bretagne et tous ces groupes ont
une sensibilité underground et à côté
allumé qu'il est distingue du monde de
la pop il s'épanouissent dans le cadre
d'une scène florissante dans l'épicentre
se trouve à West Hollywood sur les
quelques 500 mètres du Sunset Strip qui
déborde de clubs et de restaurants ici
dans des lieux comme le whisky à gogo
l'ancien ordre hollywoodien et
bouleversé et le mouvement hippie est en
marche
[Musique]
il y avait le whisky bien sûr et le trip
mais aussi de plus petit club tout le
long du boulevard
c'était la Mecque où il fallait se
rendre tu faisais partie de ces gens
super branchés qui fumaient de l'herbe
ou pas mais pour ceux qui n'étaient pas
dans le cou et ces personnes étaient
comme venues d'une autre planète tu ne
pouvais même pas leur adresser la parole
autrefois sur Suns ont trouvé le
Trocadéro le mot Cambo ou encore le
chiros d'origine c'était des night club
exclusif fréquenté par les nantilles et
les stars d'Hollywood il existe des
clichés de Charlie Chaplin de Marilyn
Monroe et d'autres stars là-bas mais ces
endroits n'étaient pas ouverts aux gens
ordinaires on ne les voyait qu'en photo
dans les magazines de cinéma
leurs clientèle avait désormais vieilli
et les artistes qui s'y produisaient
étaient partis à Las Vegas les jeunes
ont alors pris les reines de ces boîtes
de nuit
il n'y avait pas de cloisonnement des
musiciens faisaient leurs trucs et le
public faisait le sien mais c'était la
même chose
en se défonçait on voulait tous
s'engager sur la voie express qui mène à
l'illumination
la communion était totale aussi bien
mentale que physique
on vivait ça ensemble
[Musique]
c'est dans cet univers en vogue que
Charles Manson et ses quatre disciples
féminines débarquent fin 1967 Manson
cherche immédiatement à avoir un
rendez-vous avec Gary strumberg le
contact de Phil Kaufman découvreur de
talents pour Yuni records
il présente ses meilleurs compositions à
l'audition
strumberg est suffisamment impressionné
pour réserver une séance
d'enregistrement d'une heure au célèbre
studio Goldstar ou Phil Spector et Brian
Wilson des Beach Boys ont enregistré
leur plus grandes œuvres
[Musique]
la première session d'enregistrement de
Charles Manson que l'on connaît a été
faite pour Yuni records une filiale de
Universal
chose étonnante il en existe une bande
elle n'est pas montée ce qui est
inhabituel
de 20 chansons étranges d'un musicien de
rue
sans aucune orientation forme ou
structure
[Musique]
[Rires]
avant tout j'ai été surpris par la voix
de Manson
plus tard en prison
il était plus enjoué il n'arrêtait pas
de glousser et il avait l'air très
nerveux
[Musique]
[Rires]
à ce moment-là il a presque 35 ans et on
a l'impression qu'il en a à peine 20
nerveux
si on vous disait que le type avec cette
voix là allait devenir un chef de secte
je ne parle même pas des meurtres mais
simplement qu'il va donner des ordres à
des gens qui vont lui obéir au doigt et
à l'oeil
ça vous semblerait complètement absurde
bon il a quelques bonnes idées pour des
chansons des petites esquisses en tête
et c'est vrai que certaines d'entre
elles ont un réel potentiel elles
pourraient donner quelque chose
[Musique]
ton foyer c'est là où tu es heureux
quelle parole fascinante
elle ne pouvait que plaire à des jeunes
sans cadre ni domicile
rupture avec leur milieu parce qu'ils
étaient conscients que chez eux ils
n'étaient ni heureux ni libre
du coup il pouvait être adhérer à
l'utopie de Manson par le biais de cette
chanson
[Musique]
on sent une influence latine dans ses
chansons et aussi une influence
jazzrangements aussi doux enfin ils
avaient tout pour l'être
je n'aurais jamais cru que Charlie soit
capable d'une telle douceur
la séance ne convainc pas Yoni records
Manson encaisse se refuse embrancher lui
et sa famille trouve un logement
provisoire dans une maison appelée
spyrose terre case l'escalier en
colimaçon à quelque part de Topanga
Beach Manson et les jeunes filles
partagent les lieux avec divers
vagabonds toxicoman et autres marginaux
et adopte ainsi une vie communautaire
tout en travaillant sur sa musique
menson en profite pour trouver de
nouvelles recrues
en décembre 1967 Diane Lake une
collégienne de 14 ans qui a laissé
tomber l'école vient à une fête donnée
dans la maison
[Musique]
elle est une proie facile pour un ancien
détenu qui a presque le double de son
âge
[Musique]
Charlie est venu vers moi et m'a offert
de boire dans son verre apparemment il
n'y avait pas plus grand honneur il m'a
invité à me joindre cercle et à chanter
avec eux
il jouait de la guitare et toutes les
filles qui l'entouraient sont venues
pour me serrer dans leurs bras
là je me suis vraiment sentie la
bienvenue plus tard Charlie m'a pris
sous son aile et je suis tombée sous son
charme
il était drôle un peu espiègle très
enjoué
quand il secouait la tête c'est boucles
se mettaient à danser bref j'étais
attiré par lui
je le trouvais beau gosse
la jeune Dayan est tout de suite adoptée
par les autres filles de la bande de
Manson et ce pli rapidement au rituel
hallucinogène et musicaux du groupe elle
apprend toutes les paroles des chansons
de Charlie et participe à leur
divertissement collectif
[Musique]
je crois bien qu'on prenait de l'acide
au moins une fois par semaine on
s'asseyait en cercle et Charlie nous le
donnait comme un sacrement il le plaçait
sur ta langue et faisait le tour du
cercle c'était un moment spécial
la plupart du temps on faisait des bons
tripes principalement axés sur la
musique j'aimais bien sa musique
[Musique]
pourtant à l'époque il y avait beaucoup
de chanteurs guitaristes
mais en 1968 Charlie commence à se
demander si ses chances de percer ne
seraient pas plus grande s'il avait un
groupe derrière lui depuis la maison
spyrowster case et le long du Sunset
script Manson fait savoir qu'il veut
monter un groupe et qu'il est à la
recherche de jeunes musiciens talentueux
l'un des premiers à passer une audition
et le guitariste Ernest nap
s ça a été glauque d'entrée de jeu
on se sentait mal à l'aise en sa
présence
[Musique]
pour Charlie et sa famille sans les
autres musiciens
je me suis installé au milieu du salon
j'ai posé mon ampli et je me suis
branché
trois défis il y avait des instruments
de percussion des shakers un tambourin
et un petit tambour et elles m'ont
accompagné
j'ai bien aimé ça je dois l'avouer
un coup de main est toujours le bienvenu
nappe et convié à faire partie du groupe
et la semaine suivante il revient
répéter avec l'ensemble monté à la
vavite par menson
après avoir jamais un peu on a demandé à
Charlie ce qu'il avait en stock il a
alors joué pour nous je trouvais qu'il
avait du talent et que ses chansons
tenaient la route c'était plutôt un
genre d'auteur compositeur interprète
le groupe est baptisé the Milky Way la
Voie Lactée le lendemain il donne sa
seule et unique représentation en public
lors d'une audition pour jouer le samedi
soir au bar du coin le Topanga chorale
on s'est retrouvé à leur maison on a
chargé le matériel et on est allé au
Coral à plusieurs voitures
c'était un bar qui se trouvait un peu
plus haut dans le canyon
on a dû être un des premiers groupes
hippies à vouloir jouer là-dedans
c'était dans l'après-midi le patron et
d'autres gaillards étaient là
ils n'ont pas été très sympas avec nous
ils ont dit non l'unique groupe créé par
Manson et Mornay il se recentre alors
sur son travail d'artiste solo malgré
son échec le projet l'a mis en contact
avec un autre jeune musicien sur de lui
Bobby beau soleil se vante de ses
accointances avec le groupe Love et de
ses James nocturne avec Frank Zappa au
cours des deux prochaines années il sera
présent de manière sporadique dans
l'entourage de la famille Manson
il avait plus de talent que Charlie tous
ceux qui les ont vu ensemble partage le
même avis mes Beausoleil avec son esprit
artiste accrue déceler une grande
créativité chez Manson un certain lien
s'est créé entre les deux hommes
il partageait la même approche musicale
les mêmes points de vue ils étaient
assez complémentaires
mais Bobby beau soleil était un homme
fort il était indépendant d'esprit ce
qui ne cadrerait pas avec la famille
Manson
il n'en a donc jamais été membre à part
entière même s'ils ont emprunté les
mêmes chemins
mais beau soleil a de bonnes relations
comme Manson cherche à quitter la maison
Spyros terre case beau soleil suggère à
la famille d'aller s'installer à Topanga
Canyon dans une propriété vide sur
Orchies drive dans laquelle il avait
séjourné
c'est là que Philippe Kaufman ancien
camarade de prison de Manson rejoint la
famille en mars 1968 à sa sortie de
Terminal Island
connaissait une autre relation à moi
Harold true
et Harold avait été en contact avec
Charlie à ma libération Harold m'a
emmené voir Charlie je l'ai revu et il
n'avait plus rien à voir avec le type
qui chantait the shadow of your smile
sur la cour de la prison
Kaufman est fasciné par le harem de
Manson mais il est tout autant
impressionné par la transformation de sa
musique les nouveaux textes de Manson
sont clairement écrits dans le but
d'attirer plus d'adeptes
[Musique]
Manson avait un message à faire passer
un peu comme le joueur de flûte de
Hamelin il était passé de Francky Lane à
une musique sous acide
c'était son outil
parce qu'il était entouré de personnes
plus jeunes que lui et c'est ce genre de
musique qui leur plaisait
il a donné un côté folk à ses paroles
parce qu'il n'avait pas de groupe
la chanson look at your game Girl est un
bon exemple
[Musique]
et certainement la chanson la plus
complexe qui écrite Manson à l'époque
avec la superposition des harmonies avec
sa guitare et ses changements de ta peau
sa voix y remarquable
c'est difficile à dire étant donné ce
qu'on sait sur Benson mais c'est un très
beau morceau
[Musique]
on aurait dit un des marcheurs
et les filles toutes ces jeunes paumés
l'ont acheté
il a joué la carte hippie Peace and Love
et tout team et s'en est servi comme
d'un appât
l'atmosphère a Topanga n'a pourtant rien
de lugubre la paix et l'amour iraignent
et la famille se met à appliquer la
conception de Manson d'une vie
communautaire libérée de toute
préoccupation matérielle de nouveau
membre arrive et il leur apprend à vivre
simplement comme en récupérant de la
nourriture dans les benzartures c'est
une période heureuse et ses activités
communautaires sont même mentionnées
dans ses chansons
tu n'es pas pauvre et tu n'auras jamais
faim tant que tu as une benne à ordures
prenez un morceau de fromage qui est
périmé aujourd'hui on ne peut pas le
vendre le lendemain alors on le jette
mais il est très bon ce fromage tu peux
le ramener à la maison et le mettre au
frigo et c'est ce que faisait menson au
même mois
au début c'est vraiment dégoûtant les
bennes à ordures ça pue c'est sale on ne
les lave pas très souvent
bon il y avait beaucoup de cartons là
dedans mais aussi de la nourriture
on apprend vite à savoir à quelle heure
il jette les aliments
certains produits sortaient directement
du frigo oui oui on mangeait des
poubelles de l'Amérique en somme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Manson aurait voulu donner au monde et
non l'image d'un monstre qui ordonne à
des robots sans cervelle d'aller tuer
il voulait apparaître comme un être
merveilleux
qui vivait de presque rien
et qui allait être plus riche que tous
ceux qui le regardaient avec
condescendance
l'atmosphère au sein du groupe a beau
être paisible Phil Kaufman ne supporte
plus le preschi-près-cha permanent de
Manson
[Musique]
j'ai mûri c'est tout
heureusement d'ailleurs
parce que j'ai compris que si je restais
c'était la prison qui m'attendait
il était temps de sortir de là et de me
séparer de lui
le jour où je suis parti un de mes amis
est venu me chercher
j'ai dit je vais y aller Charlie il m'a
répondu je sais tu réfléchis encore pas
vrai j'ai dit oui et je vais continuer
les sermons et les activités
communautaires peuvent aider à passer le
temps mais même sonne a envie de
rencontrer des personnes du monde de la
musique il tente de côtoyer les rockeurs
qui vivent à Topanga canyon et ses
alentours
dans le même temps il envoie ses
disciples sur Sunset Strip pour qu'elles
attirent l'attention de n'importe quel
musicien et lui présenter ensuite menson
en mai 68 deux défis décrochent le gros
lot
faisait du stop à Hollywood
une voiture s'arrête pour les prendre un
jeune homme plutôt beau gosse leur dit
et vous voulez que je vous dépose les
filles et leur propose de passer chez
lui pour tromper des biscuits elle pense
comprendre ce qu'il sous-entend mais
quand elles arrivent chez lui une
demeure splendide devant un magnifique
soleil couchant il leur donner
réellement des biscuits à tremper
au bout d'un moment il leur dit qu'il
est en pleine session d'enregistrement
et qu'il doit y retourner il espère les
revoir un jour son groupe s'appelle les
Beach Boys
les deux filles rentrent sagement et
Charlie leur demande alors vous avez
rencontré quelqu'un oui un type nous a
ramassé et nous a ramené chez lui et il
est dans quel groupe les Beach Boys
Charlie en tombe de sa chaise
où habite ce titre
le Beach boy que les filles ont
rencontré par hasard n’est autre que
Dennis Wilson le batteur du groupe et
jeune frère de Bryan ce soir-là menson
est toute la famille se rendent à la
propriété de Wilson sur Sunset Boulevard
Manson veut faire bonne impression
Dennis Wilson rentre chez lui au milieu
de la nuit rouge dans son allée et voit
que les lumières sont allumées dans sa
maison un autobus scolaire égaré là et
il y a des gens chez lui
il sort de sa voiture et avance
prudemment il est riche à l'heure il se
méfie un peu
et là il est accueilli par un petit
gringalet barbu
salut mon pote comment ça va comme s'il
était l'autre de ces lieux la première
phrase qui sort de la bouche de Dennis
c'est vous allez me faire du mal alors
Charles Manson s'agenouille devant Denis
Wilson et lui baise les pieds est-ce que
j'ai l'air de quelqu'un qui veut te
faire du mal allez quoi viens et déni
entre et il découvre la famille Manson
installée chez lui avec des filles à
deux minutes vautrés partout dans sa
maison Dennis Wilson est instantanément
enchanté par Manson et ses disciples
sans vouloir ceux-ci sont tombés sur le
Beach boy le plus réceptif à leur charme
Wilson était très différent des autres
membres du groupe
c'était un sportif il faisait du surf et
bien évidemment c'était lui le tombeur
il était d'une beauté virile et il
savait s'y prendre avec des femmes les
autres étaient nettement moins attirants
que ce soit Bryan le grand daddet Carl
le petit gros qui apprenait encore à
jouer de la guitare al qui aurait pu
être dentiste et Mike qu'on imaginait
bien en pompiste alors que Dennis Wilson
était l'incarnation même des Beach Boys
dans les premières chansons sur le surf
et les voitures Brian Wilson décrivait
la vie de Dennis
la famille Manson ne pouvait pas
débarquer dans la vie de Dennis Wilson
un meilleur moment les Beach Boys
viennent de passer une mauvaise année
ils ont connu une succession de flop et
leur propre génie brian a perdu le
contrôle du groupe et souffre de
troubles mentaux à cause de sa
consommation excessive de LSD
peu de temps avant l'arrivée de la
famille Manson Dennis était en tournée
avec les Beach Boys et le marichi maesh
yogi le célèbre gourou indien est devenu
une véritable superstar depuis sa
rencontre avec les Beatles mais le
mélange méditation tend son mental
concert rock ne prend pas comme on
pouvait s'y attendre
[Musique]
ça a été une catastrophe les fans des
Beach Boys ne voulaient pas entendre le
mari et ce venu écouter le groupe ce
fichier des Beach Boys
1968 a été une année difficile pour eux
et la tournée avec le maharichi a été un
fiasco total
ils ont eu des problèmes lors des
concerts dans le sud du pays au moment
de l'assassinat de Martin Luther King il
ne faisait que perdre de l'argent les
disques ne se vendaient pas il n'était
plus en phase avec la culture de
l'époque il portait encore détenu
assorties sur scène à mon avis les Beach
Boys en 1968 c'était déjà du passé
[Musique]
sauf que Dennis refuse d'être un homme
du passé toujours ouvert aux idées
nouvelles il est fasciné par les
enseignements du Mas Richie et cherchent
un sens plus profond à sa vie les
serments de Manson qui dénoncent les
possessions matérielles et célèbres
l'unité communautaire et spirituelle le
séduisent d’emblée tout comme la
sexualité débridée des filles il invite
tout ce beau monde dans sa résidence au
14400 Sunset Boulevard
[Musique]
je me souviens qu'il était débridé il
aimait les voitures rapides et les
femmes entreprenantes si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire il vivait à 100 à
l'heure
Denise venait de sortir d'une espèce de
retraite avec le marichi
et le côté gourou de Charlie lui
convenait
je pense que Dennis c'était à la
recherche de ce genre d'inspiration
je pense qu'il trouvait ces gens
réellement intéressants
un des problèmes de déni à l'époque
c'était son sentiment de culpabilité
devant sa richesse et tous les signes
extérieurs qu'il accompagnaient
il ne pensait pas la vérité
ce n'était pas parce qu'il avait
travaillé dur ou qu'il avait du talent
mais par un simple coup de chance
Dennis Wilson vient à peine d'emménager
dans l'immense propriété qui loue sur
Sunset Boulevard après l'échec de son
premier mariage
menson et son harem ambulants sont
désormais ses invités permanents Dennis
contact son ami et collaborateur Greg
Jacobson et l'invite à se joindre à eux
la première fois que j'ai entendu parler
du sorcier comme Dennis la plaie c'est
lors d'un coup de fil de Dennis un soir
tu dois venir ici il faut que tu vois ce
type c'est le sorcier et il a plein de
filles on est d'accord je vois le
tableau mais je te rappelle que je suis
marié et que j'ai deux enfants
il s'est peut-être passé encore une
semaine avant que je ne vienne chez
Denis et là il s'était vraiment installé
chez lui
je dois reconnaître que quand Charlie
était quelque part tout le monde le
savait
dégager une telle énergie qu'on ne
pouvait pas l'ignorer c'était une
personne sympathique il était vraiment
charmant et toujours à l'écoute je peux
comprendre pourquoi Dennis l'appelait le
sorcier
il avait une capacité unique à vous
faire sentir important
il s'intéressait à vous
il n'était pas le genre à vous dire
cause toujours
la vie dans ce domaine était magique
je me défonçais et je buvais du jus
d'orange ou du jus de raisin
je regarde un souvenir divin
sa famille sa femme et à présent toutes
ces filles étaient en adoration devant
lui
elle lui cousait des vêtements
je suis persuadé qu'à ce moment-là il
était ravi par le tableau
mais il ne s'agit pas uniquement de sexe
de drogue et d'expansion de la
conscience Wilson est également fasciné
par la musique de Manson et comme Bryan
n'occupe plus le rôle de meneur des
Beach Boys les autres membres du groupe
ont envie de faire entendre leur propre
voix au sein du groupe Dennis encore
plus que les autres
[Musique]
à l'époque il apprenait à jouer du
clavier
il venait s'exercer le matin et parfois
Brian lui donnait des conseils
mais la plupart du temps il faisait ses
propres expériences
il était différent des autres Beach Boys
qui s'y connaissaient en accord en
transition ou ce genre de choses
mais il était très doué et il apprenait
vite
qu'en 1968 que Dennis a commencé à être
pris au sérieux musicalement parlant
de plus Brian avait permis aux autres de
proposer leurs idées et Dennis avait un
réel talent d'écriture
c'était un débutant mais il avait
quelque chose c'est certain
les Beach Boys viennent également de
créer leur propre labels
dans le but de signer de nouveaux
talents qui reflèteraient mieux l'époque
impressionné par les talents musicaux de
Manson Dennis Wilson espère à la fois
apprendre de son nouvel invité mais
aussi collaborer avec lui
c'est certainement la première fois que
Dennis s'intéressait à une personne et à
sa musique en même temps un peu comme un
producteur avec son artiste
a compris que sa propre expérience
pouvait être utile à Charlie
son mentor musical
ce qui est lié avant tout c'était la
musique
Dennis aimait beaucoup Charlie
et Charlie lui apprenait à jouer de la
guitare
on peut parler d'admiration mutuelle
ou même de romance
je le souvenir qu'il s'apprécier
réellement
être pris au sérieux par quelqu'un
d'aussi célèbre que Dennis a dû
conforter Manson dans l'idée qu'il avait
du talent même si Dennis n'était pas
encore un artiste à part entière il
était une superstar
et d'un coup même son travail avec
quelqu'un qui est très connu et qui
vient d'une famille très respectée dans
le milieu
Dennis Wilson tient également à
présenter son nouveau collaborateur
dynamique à un autre ami le producteur
de disque Terry matcher il est le fils
de Doris Day ainsi que le compagnon de
l'actrice montante Candice Bergen et il
occupe une place de premier plan sur la
scène musicale de Los Angeles
représente un maillon essentiel entre le
passé et le présent d'Hollywood
faisait partie du showbiz hollywoodien
et il a produit les deux premiers albums
des Birds qui ont été extrêmement
importants
obtenir sa bénédiction en susciter son
intérêt ou représenter un sacré coup de
pouce pour toute hauteur compositeur
débutant
dans les mois suivants Manson se
rapproche assez de matcher pour être
invité à la propriété de Beverly Hills
que le producteur loue sur sciero drive
Melcher et Jacobson sont sans doute ses
visiteurs les plus assidus mais de
nombreux musiciens de renom traitent
aussi régulièrement chez Dennis Wilson
la maison de déniche était un lieu de
rencontre Denis était très large
d'esprit et chacun se sentait le
bienvenus chez lui on y venait à toute
heure de jours comme de nuit alors de
nombreuses personnes y ont forcément
rencontré la famille Manson
Buffalo Springfield a été époustouflé
par le talent musical de menson
d'après ce qu'on raconte
il lui a offert une moto
et il aurait même présenté à la Warner
qui n'aurait guère été séduite
la personnalité avenante de Manson
charmer les gens le problème c'est que
quand on essaie de l'enregistrer envers
tout ça il ne reste plus que quelques
chansons sommes toutes banales on a pris
le personnage Manson en a plus même Sun
et les filles ce qui plaisait c'était
tout l'ensemble
désormais accepté dans le sein des
saints de la contre-culture de Los
Angeles Manson devient un habitué de ses
fêtes et de ses clubs et dans le centre
névralgique de ce monde le whisky à gogo
sur Sunset Strip il laisse une
impression indélébile
il y a eu un incident whisky
un soir on était tous à table avec
Charlie Dennis et Terry Melcher
également on était là à boire une bière
et à passer un bon moment ensemble et
d'un coup on a remarqué que ça s'agitait
un peu sur la piste de danse la boîte
était pleine à craquer à l'époque des
filles dansaient dans les cages le
groupe jouait à fond parce qu'il sentait
que l'atmosphère avait changé j'ai
grimpé sur ma chaise pour mieux voir ce
qui se passait j'ai dit aux autres hey
les gars regardez-moi ça
au milieu de la piste il l'avait
complètement vidé
petit à petit les gens avaient quitté
l'endroit jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus
un chat
il était comme chargé d'électricité
pour danser avec lui
son énergie était explosive
Manson laisse son empreinte dans le
milieu mais il n'empêche qu'à la fin de
l'été lui et sa famille doivent quitter
la maison de Dennis Wilson en août les
Beach Boys partent pour une longue
tournée aux États-Unis et au Canada afin
de promouvoir leur dernier album Wilson
en profite pour demander à ses invités
de quitter les lieux
il fallait bien que la fête se termine
un jour si l'on en croit les témoignages
déni sa dépensé une véritable fortune
pour la famille
cent mille dollars en nourriture en
médicament pour la gonorer en vêtements
perdus et j'en passe
il le saignait à blanc
Denis
il m'a dit tu peux nous trouver une
nouvelle maison je veux récupérer mes
affaires
j'ai fermé la maison quand Denis est
parti quand il est revenu quelques
semaines plus tard c'était dans une
nouvelle demeure
ce n'est pas la fin de leur amitié et de
leur collaboration musicale pour autant
Manson profite de l'occasion pour
installer sa famille toujours plus
nombreuse dans un endroit plus isolé
spawn ranch à 50 km au nord de la maison
de Dennis à Santa Monica était un lieu
de tournage très prisé à la grande
époque des westerns des années 1950 il
ne s'y passe désormais plus grand chose
le lieu convient donc parfaitement au
besoin de Manson
on reconnaît les chefs de secte deux ou
trois comportements types et Manson
n'échappe pas la règle
première étape trouver des personnes qui
se sentent exploitées ou persécutés et
les convaincre que vous seul pouvez les
protéger
deuxième étape les éloigner de tout
influence extérieure que ce soit à leur
famille leurs amis ou les médias qui
pourraient leur faire comprendre que
vous êtes givré
la seule voix qu'ils doivent entendre
c'est la vôtre et ça n'aurait pas marché
dans la maison de Dennis Wilson Spon
arrange en revanche est à la périphérie
de Los Angeles en termes de kilomètres
ça ne représente pas grand chose c'est
tellement près de la ville qu'on
s'attend à y trouver la même pollution
mais en réalité c'est un espace naturel
qui pourrait faire office de frontières
c'est la campagne ça ne ressemble en
rien à une grande ville et pourtant ce
n'est qu'à 25 minutes en voiture du coup
Charlie peut toujours se rendre à Los
Angeles mais il peut aussi isoler ses
disciples
la famille redevient une communauté et
sa renommée grandit dans les environs de
Los Angeles de nouveaux adeptes se
rendent dans cette oasis rustique ainsi
que des membres de gang de motards
et des personnalités du monde de la
musique
au départ la famille Manson à spawn
c'est un peu la petite maison
psychédélique dans la prairie c'était un
joyeux retour en arrière il se trouvait
sur un ancien plateau de tournage et se
déguiser en costume d'époque ont tout
insouciance ils avaient tout l'amour
libre les drogues la musique la
nourriture des bennes à ordures et même
la visite de célébrités
Dennis Wilson passait souvent il
emmenait les filles faire un tour dans
un camion poubelle on dit même que Jim
Morrison serait venu
à chacune de nos visites Manson mettait
tout en place
qu'on soit diverti oui je disais atterri
on devrait filmer tout ça ça c'est
historique en quelque sorte on n'a
jamais vu un tel spectacle il y avait
des filles des chevaux des cowboys des
hippies des motards et un grand ranch de
cinéma
si on avait voulu l'inventer on y serait
pas arrivé il fallait absolument filmer
ça
tandis que la famille s'acclimate à la
vie rurale Dennis Wilson annonce que les
Beach Boys ont accepté d'enregistrer une
des chansons sur laquelle lui et Manson
ont travaillé durant l'été
[Musique]
ce titre 6 ou existe reflète
parfaitement la vision spirituelle du
gourou
[Musique]
c'est bien plus une oeuvre de Charlie
que de Dennis parce que Charlie était
très branché philosophie orientale
de manière assez floue
sans savoir exactement quoi salut lui
plaisait c'était nouveau pour lui les
Beach Boys n'écrivaient pas sur ce type
de sujet il faisait encore des chansons
de surf ou au goodby Sun ce genre de
truc ce qui était cool en soi mais cette
chanson marque un grand changement bien
dans l'esprit des années 60
lorsque le groupe entrant en studio de
Messi de Brain Wilson pour enregistrer
le morceau en septembre 1968 il le
remodel à sa façon et lui donne aussi un
nouveau titre Neverland not to love
Steven DESPER l'ingénieur du son attitré
du groupe supervise les sessions
on savait tout ce que Dennis avait un
ami qui s'appelait Charles Manson
tous les deux en tant que musicien avait
échangé leurs idées comment le fait
toujours
ils avaient écrit ensemble c'était une
vraie collaboration entre chars et
tennis
peut-être qu'au départ l'idée de la
chanson était venue de jazz mais il
avait donné à Dennis et il avait été
rémunéré pour cela
les Beach Boys l'emprise et ils l'ont
embellie comme ils savaient le faire il
se lassoit
[Musique]
pénis qui maîtrisait bien le travail en
studio et les arrangements vocaux ces
servi de cette base et la développer en
quelque chose de plus attrayant de plus
pop
[Musique]
comme une grâce
de Dieu
je trouve que c'est une très bonne
chanson qui n'est pas reconnue à sa
juste valeur
les harmonies sont tout simplement
splendides
[Musique]
montre bien le potentiel de la
collaboration entre Dennis et Manson
elle marche vraiment bien c'est aussi
une réussite pour les Beach Boys
un album avec ce genre de titre aurait
été une bonne chose pour eux à l'époque
pourtant il n'allait pas en être ainsi
l'enregistrement aurait dû donner de
nouveaux espoirs à la famille mais à
spawn orange l'atmosphère n'est plus la
même et la communauté de Manson est en
train de se disperser la situation a
commencé à devenir tendue beaucoup de
gens ont voulu prendre leur distance on
entendait de plus en plus souvent dire
que les motards de seilton slaves
traînaient là-bas
les fleurs du Flower Power se fanaient
et laissez la place aux motos à
l'essence et au druptures
l'hiver arrivait c'était un peu comme la
fin de la saison la nuit tombée de plus
en plus tôt
une obscurité qui reflète le pessimisme
de la contre-culture en 1968
le Summer of Love n'est plus qu'un
lointain souvenir la guerre du Vietnam
s'intensifie et l'assassinat de Martin
Luther King puis celui de Robert Kennedy
fait perdre tout espoir à la jeune
génération de voir un changement
politique par la voie conventionnelle
partout dans le pays la contre-culture
prend les armes et se prépare au combat
contre les autorités de violents
affrontements au lieu dans plusieurs
villes au même moment le mouvement
pacifique pour les droits civiques sera
radicalise aussi des émeutes éclatent
après l'assassinat du pasteur King et
Black Power et le nouveau slogan de
nombreux groupes qui s'opposent à leurs
oppresseurs blancs
tous ces mouvements alimentent l'esprit
de Charles Manson qui change sincèrement
sa vision spirituelle d'une société
communautaire laisse la place à des
prédictions d'une apocalypse à venir un
soulèvement violent dans lequel les
Afro-Américains renverseraient l'ordre
établi
Nelson jongler avec des idées qui
étaient très répandues que ce soit la
guerre raciale la révolution ou
liminence de la fin d'un monde
assassinat de Martin Luther King il
s'est trouvé débordé par des
personnalités politiques noires plus
virulentes
vous voyez où même la non-violence
l'idée d'une menace qui pèserait sur la
structure même de la société liée à
l'histoire raciale pour le moins
complexe des États-Unis
a fait naître le sentiment que ses
forces étaient en mesure de prendre le
pouvoir
c'était vraiment dans l'air du temps
Manson s'empare de ses opinions assez
ordinaires pour les déformer en une
vision très singulière en septembre
conscient que le pouvoir qu'il exerce
sur ses partisans commence à s'étioler
dans un spawn ranch surpeuplé il repère
un nouvel endroit où établir sa
communauté au cœur de la Vallée de la
Mort situé à 300 km au nord de Los
Angeles barkle ranch offre un isolement
total et s'intègre parfaitement à sa
prédiction de révolution en devenir
quand les Noirs se soulèveront pour
renverser les autorités blanches la
communauté de Manson sera cachée dans
cet endroit reculé en plein désert une
fois la tempête passée ils ont sortiront
pour régner sur un nouveau monde parfait
la situation avait changé
on entendait plus parler d'amour
de communauté d'illuminations
désormais un programme était établi
Nelson ne cessait de parler de la guerre
raciale
il était persuadé qu'elle allait avoir
lieu alors il voulait nous y préparer
il fallait impérativement gagner de
l'argent
[Musique]
pour acheter des véhicules tout terrain
des couteaux et des armes et se cacher
dans le désert jusqu'à la fin de cette
guerre
alors que la musique ne semble plus être
au centre de la vie quotidienne de la
famille un disque va profondément
bouleverserenson il envoie un certain
nombre de ses disciples dans la Vallée
de la Mort aménagé leur nouveau point de
chute dans le désert tandis que lui et
les autres membres de la famille
s'installent dans une maison sur geisham
Street dans la partie nord de Los
Angeles c'est là qu'il entend pour la
première fois le nouvel opus des Beatles
le White Album l'album blanc tel qu'on
appelle communément dans un certain
nombre de leurs chansons il entend les
Beatles s'adressait directement à lui
confirmant ainsi ses prophéties d'une
violente guerre raciale
quand je suis revenue du désert à Green
Street c'était la frénésie totale
charlie avait l'impression qu'à travers
l'album blanc les Beatles lui disait que
la guerre raciale noire contre blanc
décrite par le morceau el toscalte elle
est bientôt arrivé
il l'écoutait même à l'envers
il était obnubilé par le disque il m'a
forcé à rester l'écouter et j'ai fait
pipi dans mon pantalon sur le tapis
parce qu'il ne voulait pas me laisser
aller aux toilettes tu restes là je veux
que tu écoutes ça
[Musique]
l'un des premiers morceaux dont il a
parlé il a été composé par George
Harrison George a dit plus tard que sa
mère lui avait inspiré certaines paroles
alors que Charlie pensait que les
Beatles proclamait que certaines
personnes devaient être punies ce qui
leur faut c'est une bonne grosse fessée
[Musique]
il s'agit d'une petite pique de George
Harrison à l'encontre des bourgeois
c'est tout mais bien évidemment menson
il y a vu un appel aux armes peggies est
une chanson assez violente et le mot
cochon allait jouer un rôle important
dans l'infamie perpétrée par la famille
Manson
[Musique]
Charlie a fait croire à ses disciples
que la chanson Blackbird avait un sens
particulier
même si selon Charlie les Noirs étaient
des êtres très inférieurs ils avaient
été réduits à l'esclavage et maltraitée
depuis fort longtemps et les Beatles
disaient maintenant qu'ils allaient
s'élever tu n'attendais que ton heure
pour t’élever et puis il y a le titre
phare
en Grande-Bretagne on a tout de suite
compris que Paul McCartney parler d'un
toboggan en spirale mais en Amérique
personne ne savait ce que c'était et
Charlie en a profité
[Rires]
[Musique]
en bas vous retournez en haut ce sont
les Noirs
ils sont en bas de l'échelle et vont
grimper au sommet
à la guerre raciale imminente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on était convaincu parce que ça venait
des Beatles
la guerre entre les noirs et les blancs
aller se produire
la vie au sein de la famille change du
toutou au cours des premiers mois de
1969 pour leur exode dans le désert ils
ont besoin de véhicules d'essence et
d'armes et menson reprend ses activités
criminelles pour financer ces nouveaux
projets mais son rêve musical est encore
vivant en mars Dennis Wilson réapparaît
et propose à Manson d'enregistrer une
maquette le résultat serait présenté au
Beach Boys afin de voir s'ils veulent le
signer sur leur nouveau label Brother
records l'enregistrement aurait lieu
dans le studio de Brian Wilson avec
l'ingénieur du son du groupe Steven
DESPER aux commandes c'est une occasion
inespérée
quelqu'un a frappé à la porte du studio
et a dit ton jeune talent est arrivé
je les ai accueillis à l'entrée
Charles était accompagné de cinq filles
il a sorti sa guitare et il était doué
j'ai bien vu pourquoi Denise voulait lui
faire enregistrer une maquette et le
considérer comme un artiste qu'il
pouvait signer et produire
c'est la partie production qui m'a
dérangé
une fois qu'il s'est retrouvé face au
micro il n'était plus comme les autres
tout cela lui était étranger ça l'agacé
il savait toujours mieux que les autres
devenir une rockstar célèbre n'était pas
sa priorité si ça avait été le cas il
aurait été dans tous ses états d'aller
enregistrer dans le studio des Beach
Boys
du genre qu'est-ce que je vais mettre
comment tu trouves mes cheveux
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
après la première chanson il est venu en
régie on a écouté ce qu'on venait
d'enregistrer
il a alors sorti un couteau à grande
arrêt avec une lame de 15 cm et a
commencé à curer les ongles
je lui ai dit Charlie tu vas devoir
sortir le couteau du studio
on était au domicile de Brian et sa
famille vivéla avec ses petites fial
étage je ne savais pas à quoi m'attendre
avec ce type
bref il a appelé une des filles pour
qu'elle range le couteau dans la voiture
ensuite j'ai dû les faire tous revenir
dans le studio et m'assurer qu'il ne se
baladait pas dans la maison
en tout cas il était content de sa
performance je crois qu'il est resté
trois ou quatre heures jusque tard dans
la soirée
Manson est satisfait de son
enregistrement mais il ne réussit pas à
emballer Steven DESPER qui doit rendre
compte de la session au groupe et à son
manager
j'ai apporté les bandes au bureau il
m'ont demandé comment ça s'était passé
et je leur ai répondu il n'écoute pas ce
qu'on lui dit et je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse travailler avec lui
bonnes j'aime bien les paroles vous
devriez écouter
le label Brother records n'est pas
intéressé la nouvelle n'est jamais
transmise directement à Charles Manson
mais leur silence lui fait comprendre
qu'il ne fera pas partie de leur écurie
il se tourne alors vers Terry Melcher le
producteur qu'il fréquente depuis un an
et qui vient encore de temps à autre
aspawn orange
Wilson ne peut pas lui obtenir un
contrat charlie se rend compte qu'il a
mal calculé son cou
les artistes ne sont pas au sommet de la
hiérarchie sociale
alors maintenant il a une autre cible en
tête cette cible c'est terrible
n'oubliez pas que ça fait plus d'un an
queenson tente de convaincre Melcher de
l'écouter et il se fait constamment
repousser
enfin Melcher lui dit je viendrai
t'écouter à spawn ranch il fixe une
heure et une date
on s'est tous mis à espérer en faisant
ce disque on gagnerait de l'argent
cet argent aurait servi à acheter de
l'essence des véhicules de la nourriture
et du matériel pour notre refuge dans le
désert
est un homme occupé et il a beaucoup de
choses à gérer comme les propriétés de
sa mère par exemple il ne se rend pas au
rendez-vous
pour lui c'est une broutille il n'aura
qu'à passer un coup de fil à Manson pour
s'excuser de lui avoir fait faux
bondson c'est non seulement une trahison
personnelle
mais cela met également en péril son
emprise sur ses disciples il est furieux
il part à la recherche de Terry mencher
il commence par se rendre à son adresse
sur Ciel drive mais mancheux a déménagé
lui et Candice Bergen se sont installés
au bord de la mer dans une propriété
appartenant à Doris Day
il y a désormais de nouveaux locataires
Roman Polanski et Sharon Tate constitue
l'un des couples les plus glamours de
Los Angeles ils sont les représentants
d'un Nouvel Hollywood en phase avec la
contre-culture
les films que Polanski a réalisé en
Europe au début de la décennie l'ont
fait connaître dans le monde entier et
c'est lors du tournage du dernier
d'entre eux le Bal des vampires qu'il
donne le premier rôle à charentate et
qu'il en tombe amoureux proche des amis
de Terry Mitchell et Candice Bergen le
couple a emménagé dans la maison sur
cielo drive en mars 69 et c'est à la fin
de ce même mois que Charles Manson
débarque dans le rallye fulminant à la
recherche de Melcher
le photographe personnel de sherhentate
se trouve sur les lieux il voit un petit
mec cradingue arrivé qui a l'air furieux
qu'est-ce que vous voulez je cherche
Terry Melcher et bien ici c'est la
résidence paulanski vous n'êtes pas au
bon endroit le propriétaire habite un
peu plus loin
menson dit je vais aller le voir non ne
vous approchez ni de la pelouse ni de la
maison principale mensoncy précipite
quand même le propriétaire lui dit
Melcher a déménagé et ne remettez pas
les pieds ici sans prévenir
et à cet instant une très belle femme
sort de la maison principale il la
regarde une minute puis s'en va Charles
Manson et sherhentate se sont croisés du
regard l'espace d'un instant lorsqu'il
parvient enfin à retrouver Teri Melcher
menson lui fixe un nouveau rendez-vous
et le 6 juin 1969 le producteur se rend
à spawn orange voir l'ancien détenu de
34 ans donner une prestation musicale
travaillée plusieurs semaines passent
avant que menson n'obtienne une réponse
de matcher quant à son éventuel
recommandation auprès de Columbia
Records ce n'est pas vraiment la réponse
qu'il espérait
a fini par lâcher le morceau
Charlie comptait vraiment là dessus et
je crois qu'il s'était un peu emballé
et ils ont entretenu son espoir
ils auraient dû être plus franc avec lui
dès le départ
mais il trouvait peut-être qu'il avait
vraiment quelque chose
Dennis le pensait
ça a été un véritable coup de massue
pour lui
je sais qu'il était persuadé d'avoir du
talent
tout ce dont un artiste a besoin
un producteur de disques avec des
références et un accès à un grand studio
le coup a donc été rude pour lui
les événements tragiques qui vont suivre
seront alimentés par ce rejet et par le
caractère désespéré des activités
chaotiques de la famille à nouveau
Manson se révèle être un incorrigible
malfrat
[Musique]
au moment où Charlie met ses adeptes en
garde contre helter Skelter et leur dit
de retourner dans le désert il se met à
dîner de la drogue pour gagner l'argent
nécessaire à leur retraite
l'affaire tourne mal Charlie tire sur
l'autre sapopa avec un pistolet Buntline
spécial de calibre 22 un vieux pistolet
de cowboy qu'il a apporté et pense
l'avoir tué
du coup il est persuadé que les Black
Panther sont maintenant sans prendre à
la famille Manson charlie avait beau
parler d'une apocalypse raciale en terme
emphatique il avait une trouille bleue
des Black Panthers
ce deal calamiteux en juillet 1969 est
suivi d'un événement plus grave encore à
la fin du mois Bobby bo-soleil la colite
épisodique de la famille gère un trafic
de drogue son fournisseur est le
professeur de musique Gary hilman et ses
clients le gang de motard les streets
sont des visiteurs réguliers de Spawn
ranch quand les motards accusent
Beausoleil de leur avoir fourni de la
drogue de piètre qualité il se renditman
avec trois membres de la famille pour
récupérer son argent une bagarre éclate
la situation dégénère totalement et il
reste dans l'appartement de Hyman
au bout de deux jours Beausoleil achève
Hillman lui et ses complices inscrivent
des messages avec le sang du musicien
sur les murs il ne faut que deux
semaines à la police pour arrêter le
meurtrier peut-être plusieurs membres de
la famille Manson étaient impliqués dans
la mort de Gary en particulier Bobby
il n'était pas un membre à part entière
de la famille mais à bien des égards il
y était étroitement lié
à ce moment là il faisait également du
trafic de drogue avec la famille
apparemment Nelson aurait Diabo soleil
tu sais ce que tu dois faire
ce qui aurait conduit à la mort de
hilman beau soleil perd tout contrôle et
il est très vite retrouvé couvert de
sang on établit le lien avec le meurtre
et beau soleil est arrêté mais son a
peur que tout ceci lui retombe dessus
il n'a peut-être pas prononcé cette
phrase exacte mais tous les faits mènent
à lui comme le trafic de drogue organisé
depuis
l'aide de Manson
la police allait forcément remonter
jusqu'à lui
Manson a peur d'être mêlé à l'affaire
beau soleil il déclare alors qu'il est
temps de passer à elterskelter il envoie
quatre de ses disciples dans la nuit à
Los Angeles comme être un meurtre du
même acabit avec à leur tête texte
Watson alors âgé de 24 ans ils ont deux
buts premièrement de nouveaux crimes
doivent amener la police à croire en
l'innocence de Beausoleil et établir la
preuve que le tueur est toujours en
liberté deuxièmement il faut que les
soupçons de la police se dirigent vers
les Afro-Américains ce qui déclenchera
la guerre raciale Manson veut des cibles
de premier plan et il envoie son groupe
de chasseurs à l'ancienne résidence de
Thierry Melcher sur Ciel au drive
et ça n'a été qu'une question de lieu
il fallait tuer des gens célèbres et
faire porter la responsabilité au Black
Panthers pour disculper Bobby bosoleil
l'endroit peuplé de Jean riche et
célèbre que Manson connaissait le mieux
était ciel au drive le successeur de
Melcher à cette adresse était forcément
quelqu'un d'important la deuxième raison
essentielle à ce choix c'est que texte
Watson était le seul avec Charlie à
avoir été dans cette demeure il savait
donc en théorie comment s'y rendre
depuis spawn ranch
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont choisi cette
maison
les meurtres du 8 août 1969 compte parmi
les crimes les plus violents de l'époque
Sharon Tate et 4 autres victimes ont été
tués sur le moindre état d'âme
la folie meurtrière se poursuit la nuit
suivante avec les meurtres tout aussi
violents d'un couple de riches bourgeois
Rose-Marie et Lino la Bianca
encore une nuit sanglante mais ce qui
est intéressant sur le plan musical
c'est que c'est lors de cette nuit qu'il
décide de barbouiller mort au cochon sur
les murs la veille ils avaient inscrit
le mot cochon en référence au Beatles et
l'élément clé de cette nuit là c'est
alter Skelter écrit sur la porte du
frigo j'ai le sentiment que si les
meurtres de cette nature ont cessé à
partir de ce moment-là c'est qu'à leur
retour à spawng ils ont bien dû faire le
compte-rendu de leur épopée amenson et
en apprenant que Patricia kraain Lincoln
avait écrit elters avec du sang sur le
réfrigérateur menson a paniqué tout le
monde connaissait ses théories et son
obsession pour elterscalter il y avait
même une boîte de nuit à ce moment qui
portait ce nom c'est à ce moment-là que
Manson a pris peur et que le
déménagement à barther ranch a eu lieu
mais même son est encore à court
d'argent il ne se préoccupe plus de ses
relations dans le monde de la musique
mais estime qu'on lui doit encore de
l'argent pour l'enregistrement de systo
existent des Beach Boys Dennis on a
changé les paroles sans même lui
demander l'autorisation il parcourt Los
Angeles à la recherche du batteur et le
retrouve finalement en compagnie de Greg
Jackson et du photographe des Beach Boys
Edwards
[Musique]
c'était juste après le début du festival
de Woodstock c'est-à-dire une ou deux
semaines après les événements assis et
le drive
dans la pièce il avait la même tête que
dans les journaux avec ses cheveux
hirsutent il a dit je reviens de la lune
je l'ai reconnu [__] c'est ce type
Charlie Charlie s'est adressé à Dennis
il faut que je te parle et ils ont
quitté la pièce
il ne l'avait plus il a dit j'ai dû lui
donner tout mon fric et la guitare sinon
il allait kidnappé mon fils dans la
matinée et le tuer
tout ça à cause de la chanson
[Musique]
l'épisode marque la fin de leur relation
et la fin des liens de Manson avec la
scène musicale de Los Angeles la semaine
suivante lui ses disciples partent en
buggy en direction du désert
tandis que les forces de police de Los
Angeles s'efforce de faire avancer les
enquêtes sur les affaires Tate et la
Bianca dans la Vallée de la Mort la
communauté récemment installée attire
très vite l'attention des forces de
l'ordre local
en octobre après de décembre la police
arrête la famille Manson après avoir
découvert leur Flottis de buggivolet
Charles Manson et certains des assassins
sont placés en détention mais sur la
base d'accusation beaucoup moins grave
Susanna Keynes un membre de la famille
qui a pris part aux deux agressions se
vante d'avoir commis des meurtres auprès
d'une autre détenue c'est l'indice dont
les enquêteurs avaient besoin
après avoir établi le lien entre les
différents volets du dossier en
interrogeant les fidèles de Manson la
police de Los Angeles et le procureur
sont convaincus d'avoir trouvé les
meurtriers
il donne une conférence de presse le
premier décembre 1969 pour annoncer que
l'affaire est résolue
Charles Manson et sa famille sont
désormais tristement célèbres
[Musique]
personnellement j'étais un peu incrédule
au début parce qu'il n'avait pas l'air
si méchant que ça d'accord il est un peu
bizarre mais de là commettre une chose
pareille et je ne pensais pas non plus
que les filles qui étaient venus dans le
studio étaient capables de poignarder
des gens
quand j'ai lu la nouvelle ça m'a
chamboulé quoi comment j'étais en état
de choc je n'y croyais pas au début
j'avais du mal à croire à quel point les
filles avaient changé
elles sont allées dans ces maisons et
ont massacré des gens on était loin de
abandonne-toi à l'amour de la chanson
elles ont sauvagement assassiné des gens
et quelqu'un m'a appelé tu as entendu ce
qui s'est passé
quand on m'a annoncé la nouvelle je n'ai
pas été surpris pas le moins du monde
ça me paraissait logique que ce soit
aller aussi loin la situation était
devenue incontrôlable
le monde de la musique est pris de
panique Nelson et les meurtriers sont
désormais derrière les barreaux mais
beaucoup de membres de la famille sont
encore libres
persuadé qu'il était la véritable cible
de l'attaque menée à cielo drive Thierry
Melcher en particulier et dévoré par
l'angoisse tous ceux qui ont eu des
contacts avec Manson d'une manière ou
d'une autre façon cherche à protéger
leur réputation et à prendre leur
distance avec cette affaire
[Musique]
de calibre 12 avec un canon coursier
ainsi
il était très inquiet délice un peu
moins il prenait ça un peu plus à la
légère mais terrible lui était très
préoccupé il ne savait pas de quoi ces
gens étaient capables et ils ne
voulaient prendre aucun risque
j'ai reçu un appel du management des
Beach Boys ils m'ont dit qu'ils allaient
prendre les bandes pour les mettre en
lieu sûr il voulait s'assurer qu'il n'y
ait pas de copie
pour un endroit tenu secret
personne ne savait où il était mais on
sentait bien que Dennis était menacé
en prison alors qu'a priori Dennis
n'était plus en danger
sa personnalité a changé il n'était plus
du tout le même
il est devenu paranoïaque
de toute cette histoire
le procureur chargé de la faire cher
cherche à avoir des témoins pour le
procès il constate que les relations de
Manson dans le monde du showbiz n'ont
pas l'intention de ternir leur
réputation en venant témoigner à la
barre
ne voulait pas coopérer avec bollywoody
et termine aujourd'hui encore je suis
persuadé que Théo a passé un accord avec
le procureur mais j'en ignore les termes
bouliosi voulait citer à comparaître des
Nice un beach Boy ou Candice Bergen la
petite amie Terry mais pour Terry
c'était tout bonnement inconcevable
moi j'étais là alors j'ai coopéré
je n'ai rien vu de répréhensible une
arme ce genre de trucs
pendant ce temps Manson tente de garder
l'emprise qu'il a sur ses disciples
depuis la prison pour y parvenir il lui
faut gagner de l'argent il est à présent
à la une des journaux du monde entier
menson considère que c'est donc le
moment idéal pour sortir un disque son
rêve de devenir une rockstar ne veut pas
mourir
Manson trouvait que les bandes
enregistrées chez Brian Wilson était
excellente
elle pouvait représenter l'unique
occasion pour lui de s'exprimer
musicalement l'idée lui plaisait de plus
il avait des frais de justice à payer
non seulement pour lui-même mais aussi
pour les femmes inculpées il devait à
tout prix garantir leur loyauté
leurs avocats respectifs voulaient qu'on
traite leur dossier séparément de celui
de Manson pour prouver qu'elles avaient
été manipulées par cet homme Charlie
devait s'assurer de contenter tout le
monde
quel meilleur façon de se faire de
l'argent qu'en sortant le grand album
qui ferait de lui une rock star tout en
couvrant ses frais de justice
Nelson engage Lynette from surnommé
squicky dans la famille pour mener à
bien le projet elle découvre que les
enregistrements du studio de Brian
Wilson sont souclés alors elle persuade
Greg Jacobson de lui donner les bandes
d'une session qu'il avait organisée au
sens City studio au milieu de 1968 elle
appelle ensuite Phil Kaufman pour
l'aider à sortir le disque et Kaufman
qui croit alors à l'innocence de Manson
accepte de lui rendre ce service
m'a contacté il faut qu'on fasse un
temps dans la musique de Charlie
d'après de Charlie en écoutant son album
les gens comprendraient que ce qu'il
faisait était bien
donc elle a récupéré les bandes et je
les ai apporté au studio on les a un peu
nettoyés on a fait le mixage après j'ai
demandé à des gens de ce côté et on a pu
en tirer 300 exemplaires et pour finir
on a pris la couverture du magazine Life
en supprimant le F de Life et c'est
devenu l'ail le mensonge car c'est bien
un mensonge il est innocent quand on
entend sa musique comment on peut
l'accuser d'une chose pareille
[Musique]
voici un des albums originaux
on le voit à son étiquette jaune
tout le reste ce sont des copies pirates
il m'a demandé de sortir l'album et je
l'ai fait aujourd'hui encore je regrette
profondément d'avoir été mêlés à Manson
mais on ne peut pas divorcer de son
passé
à sa sortie le disque ne rencontre pas
le succès que menson escompté même son
côté sulfureux ne fait pas vendre
la carrière de musiciens de Manson
semblait sans grand intérêt aux yeux des
personnes qui lisaient les gros titres à
l'époque on le voyait plus comme le
gourou d'une secte que comme un musicien
il était difficile d’écouter sa musique
en faisant abstraction de l'horrible
carnage qui avait eu lieu au mieux le
disque a été considéré comme une
curiosité mais pour la plupart des gens
c'était de très mauvais goûts
aucune maison de disques n'allait le
publier et aucune radio ne le passerait
ce n'est qu'un autre exemple de la
naïveté désespérée dont a fait preuve
Manson qui pensait que tout le monde
aurait envie d'acheter son album
le procès Manson devient un gigantesque
cirque médiatique et la contre-culture
elle-même doit se débattre avec ce
gourou et ses références hippies Ronald
Reagan alors gouverneur de la Californie
et le premier à lancer une croisade
contre les idéaux de ce mouvement suivi
par le président du moment Richard Nixon
les valeurs conservatrices américaines
se révèlent plus solide que ne le
pensait la contre-culture
si certains tentent de politiser les
meurtres-têtes et la Bianca en faisant
de Manson de manière peujudicieuse un
leader révolutionnaire la majorité
reconnaît simplement que ses actes
dramatiques et choquants ternissent à
jamais un mouvement qui prenait l'amour
et la paix
[Musique]
je ne crois pas que Charles Manson avait
le dessin de détruire le rêve hippie
[Musique]
on a dit que dès l'instant où on
décembre 1969 menson a fait la une des
journaux toute personne qui avait l'air
hippie était diabolisée
si vous étiez quelqu'un de droite qui
unissait tout ce que la contre-culture
représentait
vous ne pouviez pas trouver mieux que
Charles Manson et ses meurtres
abominable
tous les éléments la tablette
la violence et même les Beatles
la confiance en l'autre et l'absence de
crainte ce sont vraiment les grandes
forces de l'esprit humain mais bien sûr
on peut se fourvoyer et c'est là l'un
des vrais chocs avec Manson
on a parfois sympathisé avec les
mauvaises personnes
pour beaucoup de ceux qui se sont liés
d'amitié avec Charles Manson il restera
présent à jamais dans leur vie bien
qu'il soit devenu l'incarnation du mal
dans la culture populaire un fou furieux
au cerveau dérangé il reste un
personnage authentique et complexe pour
ceux qui se sont plongés dans son
univers musical et de l'avoir côtoyé les
marquera à vie Dennis Wilson croyait
réellement en cet homme qui l'appelait
le sorcier et il est parti à la dérive
après la nouvelle choquante des meurtres
jadis force vive des Beach Boys Dennis a
été hanté par cette terrible amitié qui
n'a jamais pu oublier
petit à petit il s'est perdu dans
l'alcool et la drogue il est mort en
1983 à l'âge de 39 ans seulement depuis
le jour de l'arrestation de Manson il a
toujours refusé de s'exprimer
publiquement sur la faire
[Musique]
Dennis n'en n'a jamais parlé et je ne
trouvais pas que c'était à moi d'aborder
le sujet il n'en a pas dit un mot
[Musique]
je suis sûr que dans une certaine mesure
il se sentait responsable il avait été
très impliqué dans cette histoire
Dennis n'a jamais évoqué les meurtres à
proprement parler il se remémorait
parfois ses expériences avec la famille
mais jamais
je ne sais pas à quel point
il a toujours évité de parler des
[Musique]
ne s'est jamais vraiment remis du choc
émotionnel qu'il a subi
il était déjà le mouton noir du groupe
avant
évoluer et à devenir un artiste qu'on
pouvait prendre au sérieux
[Musique]
c'est en tout cas l'image qu'il avait de
lui-même
son entourage a tenté désespérément de
le convaincre qu'il valait mieux que ça
[Musique]
je crois qu'il ne s'en est jamais remis